انا اليوم ترين جديد في الارجنتين مبابي
يردوا على احتفاليه مارتنز وبلبل مصاب
يتمتعوا بالثلوج هذه الاخبار وغيرها
نقدمها لكم من العربيه رياضه اهلا بكم
انا اليوم عباره اصبحت تراند في الارجنتين
بسبب تواضع النجم ميسي الذي عرف بنفسه من
خلال رساله ارسلها عبر حساب انستغرام
لاولاده هو الرابع لزوجته ان تونيلا
المرسم نشر هذه الرساله التي تفعل معها
الكثيرون لتواضع ميسي الظاهر في المحادثه
الخاصه
وعلى ما يبدو سيغير ميسي طريقه تعامله مع
السوشيال ميديا ليصبح اكثر تفاعلا قائد
الارجنتين نشر ستوري على انستغرام اثناء
متابعته لمباراه فريق سان جيرمان في
الدوري الفرنسي وهو شيء لم يعتد ليوعلى
فعله كما كسرت صوره في الاونه الاخيره
العديد من الارقام القياسيه للاعجابات على
موقع التواصل
وبعد انتهاء مباراه السان جيرمان تحدث
مبابي على الاحتفال مليون ومارتينيز حارس
الارجنتين والذي سخره في ممكن يعني الشاب
الفرنسيه
وتحدث معه ولكنه لا يركز على احتفالات
غيره ولا يريد اضاعته طاقتي طاقته ووقته
في الحديث او الرد عليها مضيفا بان على
اللاعبين على الاقتداء بكابتن الارجنتين
ليو ميسي داخل وخارج الملعب
بسبب الاصابه لم يلعب اي مباراه مع
يوفنتوس منذ انتقاله الى النادي الايطالي
السيف الماضي وهو ما دفع عام في سيده
العجوز للاستغراب من اللاعب الفرنسي الذي
نشر صورا له في مرتفعات خاصه بالتزلج لكن
الطلبه انا متابعي قائلا بانه التقط الصور
بغرض نشرها مضيفا بانه لم يقم بالتزلج
خاصه وان موعد عودته للمشاركه اصبح قريبا
[موسيقى]